c'est parti on les regarde sa couleur
ses mobiles à séoul non c'est bizarre
débile pitbull ou renault leurs
taxes ou rex
ouais bravo bravo la joe cocker on vit
le caniche c'est tabou caire bah ouais
c'est plutôt plus tard c'est plutôt
travaux finaux chinois voilà
ma fille née sourde au chihuahua six
mois
film suit avoir la réponse si voilà
maintenant
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
grossouvre
d'être celle où russell crowe c'est bien
beau faire j'ai foncé ou verger allemand
vise à fonder dit pas du tout mais
regarde les images et franchement on
voit les yeux et puis faut aussi mais
pas du tout l'étalement tu là
ce genre j'ai pensé à ces chips youtube
sous le titre we shekels au
frigo oui bravo
car des avocats
[Applaudissements]
bonjour
oh
oh la la
remise à leur merci tu nous a fait
gagner des tonnes de croquettes
[Applaudissements]
je crois comme de vrais qu'on aura
intérêt les couper le micro casque et un
rang elle est souple et
suzuki- d'avoir wayne rooney leur bon